quantitative easing is a it's a
completely lunatic program that is
interestingly not very well known here
in America remember when Barack Obama
had is 800 billion dollar stimulus
package which was ostensibly intended to
create jobs there was up where all
across the country that this is
socialism and how could we do this just
the government giving money away well
that was actually real money that
existed that eight hundred billion
dollars that they spent ostensibly
creating jobs quantitative easing was a
program where the Federal Reserve did
like an I Dream of Jeannie thing and
like invented out of thin air now two
trillion dollars essentially to buy
t-bills and mortgage-backed securities
and artificially prop up Wall Street and
this is money that didn't even exist and
they simply were pumping it into the
financial bloodstream so that you know
Wall Street could stay alive a little
bit longer it's a completely insane
program you know there's a reason why
you can't just print money and and you
know get yourself out of economic
trouble that way there's a tremendous
inflationary danger here but they're
doing it anyway which speaks to the
total desperation and craziness of our
current economy